un nouveau défi comme il en apparaît des
dizaines chaque année sur les réseaux
sociaux mais le dernier né est aussi
absurde que dangereux il consiste à
couper un morceau de son baume à lèvres
dès que l'on se sent mal quand le tube
évident les jeunes sont appelés à se
faire du mal jusqu'au suicide
des dizaines de vidéos musique
angoissante à l'appui sans que l'on
sache toujours si l'intention de se
faire du mal est réel ou si ce n'est
qu'une manière d'attirer les internautes
sur son profil pour l'heure aucune
tentative de suicide lié au défi n'a été
recensé vendredi le ministère de
l'intérieur a posté ce message de
prévention une cellule d'écouté
joignable au tronc 18 est disponible
pour les adolescents et les parents
on peut juste préciser qu'au départ le
challenge il était plutôt cool ce compte
mais ténu les vélos et le voisin devait
deviner en l'embrassant l'odeur de mois
la belle au goût c'est ça c'est ça sauf
qu'il ya une dérive ouais euh excusez
moi des imbéciles des malades mentaux ça
s'appelle comme ça et qui pousse ce
challenge finalement à la dérive alors
tombé apparemment hélène bosque ne
rachetait au rachat de twitter il ya
plus de tous ses habitants bien assez
pour que tu as raison on sait pas mais
pas la raison pour l'instant mieux
d'accord pourquoi l'état où il vaut
mieux pas s'il voulait réintégrer trump
mais il s'en [ __ ] bah ouais je m'en
fous
c'est très bonne explication et vous
vous aimez les lumières vous êtes rentré
en fait
j'adore le public
labello ça franchement ça fait peur très
très sérieusement enfin que font les
modérateurs c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné quand c'est à ce genre de
challenge qui arrive qu'on voit que ça
commence avrillé et à partir un tout
petit peu en cacahuètes mais il faut
prendre tik tok supprimer tout ce qui
est en rapport avec le challenge car
moment donné on va attendre à chaque
fois qu'ils aient des drames on se
rappelle qu'avec le jeu du foulard dans
les cours de récréation où les jeunes
s'amuser à s'étouffer qui avait eu une
jeune c'est en italie ou en espagne qui
était morte à un moment donné il va
falloir qu'ils aient des choses qui se
passent il faut prendre ces réseaux et
essayer de faire des choses d'interdire
de les couper ou je sais pas mais quand
je crois que c'est
le gouvernement qui va arriver des roues
vous savez quand à propos vous êtes l'a
ccord le ont valeur au barça marquant
bay lundi les ministres des ministres
chéquier donc là c'est bernard
j'ai cru comprendre que malgré les berda
était à terme en postuler pour des
raisons des ministères sociaux non alors
en fait je voulais maintenant parce que
j'ai un travail et prenant quand un
ministre il faut s'y consacrer à 100%
donc forcément moi j'ai ma boîte qui
tourne bien j'ai pas j'ai pas par contre
est déconseillée et médecins en tête
pourquoi j'ai dit ça parce que je savais
que ça allait faire rire tout le monde
et je voulais mettre la lumière sur
cette cause et je savais que ça allait
être repris dans la presse donc oui il
faut mettre un ministère faut faire un
ministère d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
quand j'irai pas les messieurs non il ya
un ministère au numérique excusez moi
qui ai tellement effacé par rapport à ce
qui se passe sur les réseaux sociaux que
pour moi qui travaille et qui easy entre
guillemets il n'existe pas à quoi et
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait cette alerte
la entre guillemets à la milice moment
ne fera pas reconduit non plus on sait
pas c'est pareil on sait rien arranger
terriens ont sérieusement de spéculation
par tous afin de décider si le président
nous regardent sachez que magali berda
mais en face aux médias parce que dire
donc ce que j'aimerais fusion alors
a répondu que c'était un sujet qui était
prioritaire pour lui cette pendant ce
cas ce nouveau quinquennat et que oui on
pourrait se mettre autour d'une table il
me recevra pour discuter de la création
qui dit dans la bande am un terme au
gouvernement al attar
avons donné mon expérience
[Applaudissements]
comme on dit souvent voilà la vie
n'oubliez pas que quand on monte on peut
croiser ceux qui descendent on imagine
qu'il vous
conseillez moi c'est mon expérience qui
peut dire beaucoup de choses c'est donc
pour finir sur le vélo voilà si vous
faites c'est deux choses la balle assez
c'est assez stupide que dangereux pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'accidents
recensés et non pour l'instant qu'en
disent les signes tendent à voile aérien
mais bon soyez vigilants et si les
parents nous regarde oui votre enfant
qu'il faut saluer c'est qu'il ya eu en
masse sur tik tok énormément
d'influenceurs qui ont essayé de
positiver un nouveau challenge est de
mettre en place des nouveaux challenge
sympathique et machin du coup qui a fait
de prendre un peu conscience à ces
jeunes que c'était de la connerie donc
il faut regarder il ya une vraie
réaction qu'a eu lieu depuis qu'elle
adore les défis en fait ben oui mais ce
qu'ils veulent c'est pas des challenge
sympathique aujourd'hui sont prêts à
tout pour ses remarques et cédric
sociaux avant c'était se mettre à poil
maintenant c'est dire je suis dépressif
et j'ai fait une tentative de suicide il
ya aussi ça qui est insupportable c'est
être prêt à tout pour aider la région de
l'aquila et moi franchement ça ne fait
pas ton peur que ça on a vu il ya même
eu une tentative de suicide c'est
surtout attirer l'attention sur soi en
racontant n'importe quoi et cette quête
du buzz elle est dangereuse